welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 11 and
we're gonna learn how billionaires
refuse
to quit enjoy
[Music]
when i started the first interact
companies of two
with my brother and another person um a
great curry
the uh it wasn't really with the thought
of being wealthy
you know got anything against being
wealthy but um
we'll get back to that later but it's
just it was just from the standpoint
i've been wanting to be part of
the internet and uh i i figured if we
could make enough money to
just get by it would be that'll be okay
um and when we started off uh
we we literally only had like one
computer and so it would be our web
server during the day and i'd code at
night
and we we just got a a small office
um in palo alto back when rent was not
insane um and uh
it cost us like 450 dollars a month it
was cheaper than an apartment so we
actually just slept in the office
and then and then showered at the ymca
at pagemail el camino
so we'd walk over there and and shower
and
that was actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um
and uh so i don't know how many people
probably know many people know this but
uh
uh we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on uh the zip2 business plan and
actually i thought she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most people we met did not
actually read our business plan
in fact a lot of people a lot of venture
capitalists at the time didn't even
know what the internet was or they've
never used they've never used that
they're sure
that things still do yeah right
yeah i'm talking like you know sort of
well-known people on san diego was like
wow okay
but at the time nobody made any any
money on the internet so i guess
that's um you know there wasn't really
clear evidence that there was was a
business
when i got to dallas i was a bartender
at night and
i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there
you know my car would only get so far i
had a fiat x19 with a hole in the
floorboard that
guzzled oil every 60 miles and i went
down there and this place called the
village it's the world
was the world's largest apartment
complex we had six guys in a
three-bedroom apartment
i didn't have my own room i didn't have
my own drawer i didn't have my closet
i had a pile and i had one ratty towel
that i stole from
motel 6. and that was it and so
i was looking for my career got a job at
a software store
and i was you know i was didn't have a
tech background so i was teaching myself
all this
because the way i look at tech is
somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it
and if if i work harder and faster
to really dive in if it means reading
the manual you know
just diving in then i can get a head
start
i was 24. and so sleeping on the floor
working in a software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better what i
was doing
and then one day because i was dying to
get out of that rat hole that i lived in
um i had a chance to go out and close
the sale
for that would have got me a 1500
commission and so i went to my boss his
name is michael humecki
and i said boss one of my
responsibilities was to sweep the floor
wipe down the windows and open the door
to open the store i got the sale you got
to let me close the sale
he goes no you've got to be in there to
open the store and i'm like
michael i mean no so i made the
executive decision
to go out pick up the check thinking if
i hand this guy a 15 000
check of course he's going to change his
mind
fired me on the spot and so here i was
living in all excuse my french you know
just this ratty place with
a motel six towel sorry motel six um
and and really didn't know how i was
going to get out but
i went to i decided okay i'm a lousy
employee i went to
um one of the companies that i've been
talking to architectural lighting
and i said look um i need 500 to be able
to buy the software you want and i
promise you
that even if it doesn't work i will wash
your car you know i will walk your dog i
don't care
what it is i will do whatever it takes
to make it up to you and they gave me
the 500
and that allowed me to create micro
solutions and you know six months later
i was out of the rat hole and
my company turned into a real company
and that's the one i sold
for six million dollars when i was 29 30
years old i went through some tough
times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say and the audience
had heard it that i would move on
and that i would not spend my life
regretting or trying to hold on to what
used to be or hold on to what i had
so i dreamed this dream of starting a
network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because i didn't
honestly goodness i did not know what i
was doing
i was trying to figure it out i was
trying to figure it out
i thought that the oprah show audience
would follow us to own
and then i realized y'all didn't have
cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so so it took me a minute and
unlike most people who you get to have
your mistakes in private
some don't go right in your life you get
to sulk about it in private
if i make a mistake it's on the cnn
crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're going to stand
with you we're going to stand by you
thank you roland martin
there were so many people who said
listen we believe that this can happen
so i dreamed the dream along with tyler
perry who was my friend who came to me
and said
tyler tyler said i'm going to help you
out cause tyler can go home and write a
script and
direct it produce it and shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation
of having have not
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall
but the righteous will rise and thrive
like a green leaf my goal was to create
the perfect job for me
a job i truly loved i never ex
i never expected the company to grow
beyond 50 people
so maybe i really did lack ambition
or vision back then i don't know
it was a long time ago and i was very
young
anyway today oracle employs around 150
000 people but when i started
it was not my intention to build a big
company
what happened well at first we did
exactly what we set out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company i call it
a crazy idea
because at the time everyone told me it
was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published
and ibm was building a prototype in
their research labs
but back then the collective wisdom of
computer experts
was that while relational databases
could be built
they would never be fast enough to be
useful
i thought all those so-called
computer experts were wrong
and when you start telling people that
all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates when people
start
telling you that you're crazy you just
might be on to the most
important innovation in your life it
wasn't so
so long ago that you know i was a
student
and you know sitting in a seat in an
auditorium like
uh you guys are here today listening to
i remember very specifically this time
when bill gates came to talk it
at harvard and i'm just like wow
how do you how do you do that um and
but you know the trick is is that
the media likes to sensationalize this
as if
you have some eureka moment or you
are some singular person who i can't
build something on your own and that's
just not how the world works
um you know when i was in school i built
a lot of stuff that i just liked
building there was not a single moment
when i when i had some revelation that
facebook was gonna be
awesome that's not maybe how the media
or movies or whatever would like to
portray things it's not it's much less
exciting but
the reality is i think most uh
services in the world that reach the
scale that facebook has
you start off building something that
you care about and you know you don't
necessarily think it's going to be that
big
i didn't you know i built facebook the
first version of facebook
for my college community because i
wanted to be able to connect with the
people at my school
and i remember very clearly talking to
my friends
at the time and saying you know it's how
cool is it that we have built this
community for our school
you know one day it's going to be
awesome when somebody else builds this
for the world because something like
this needs to exist for the world but
it didn't even occur to me that you know
my friends and i might
be able to play a role in doing that
right because we were college students
right i mean we didn't
have any you know engineers to to work
with or
servers or resources or anything like
that and you know there are these
huge companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people
right there's you know i always assume
that it was going to be like microsoft
or
google or someone would build this for
the world and
what basically just happened is um at
each step along the way we just kind of
kept
doing the next thing and uh growing from
there
and you know there were teams inside
these other companies that
that thought social media was important
and we're working on it but
you know there were all these different
memes and narratives uh
in the world you know people would say
oh well you know this is just a fad
people are going to use it but then
they're going to stop
so um you know so a lot of the teams
were working on didn't take it that
seriously
or you know the higher ups and those
companies didn't care so they didn't get
resources and
we just kept going and going and then
people would say all right well
all right fine so maybe people are using
it but it's never gonna make any money
right i mean social media doesn't make
any money
then we just kind of kept going and
going and then
pretty soon we had a service that was uh
bigger than
any of these other ones and that kind of
is how we are here where we are
um there's no magic a lot of times i
think people just get afraid
because you know often your dream is
it's it seems like it's so
um so far off but but if you just kind
of focus on building stuff that you
think is good and
uh and and you keep on going at each
step along the way and don't let people
deter you from that and
you just really care about what you're
doing and kind of don't give up but each
step along the way then
um you know i think that's how you
that's how you build something good
if jackman can be successful succeed
80 percent of the young people can be
successful we don't have money
we don't have a relationship i don't
have a powerful rich
father even though we don't have a rich
father or uncle
that can sponsor us everything we do
is the 18 founders we believe the future
we make progress even among the 18
founders
we only have a three engineers amount of
three engineers
only one of them had three years
experience at university
studied computer the other two
they are like amateur computer they when
they open it they don't know how to fix
it
[Music]
start from there to today we have 25
000 engineers in our company
and nobody come to buy and sell
for the first two weeks terrible we
build our e-commerce company
nobody come to sell so we have to list
our own products on there
waited for two weeks nobody come to buy
so we have to buy ourselves
and then the first first month
some people come to sell things on our
site we buy everything so we buy a whole
house of rubbish
for the whole house we started nobody
believed
e-commerce until today or last year
we sold 550 billion u.s dollars
from nothing to 550 billion dollars
and i think compared to yesterday was
big sales
but compared to 10 years later we are
nothing
this is what i want to say the great
ideas i heard in the next room
in spite of me and changed my
you are guys at the hope of africa
and i believe 15 years ago 13 years
18 years in my apartment i told my team
we are the hope
of china because we are the guys without
any resources
if we can make it the most people can
make it
if most people like us with other money
without resources
only with the dream and belief if we can
make succeed
china will be successful so of all the
things in the world that you could say
are like the secrets
that being positive is one of the main
things that people need to do
how did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me
when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place
they move along in life faster they're
better and people want to be around
these people
i mean too often people gossip then one
gossip person wants to be around the
other person that gossips
but they don't realize when you gossip
you're saying
something you heard about somebody else
you're telling everybody
what if part of it was wrong you're
gonna go out and tell every person you
told this oh
i'm sorry it was wrong tell everybody
you told it's not gonna happen
so it seems to learn about don't gossip
don't build little people if you don't
have to
god please don't try and look at the
positive angle
what good could come out of something
and that positiveness
is gonna make you live longer happier
and wake up in the morning happy not oh
my god i gotta go to work i can't wait
till i get home i wanna retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire
they hate their job they retire three or
four years later they're dead because
they have nothing to do
that positive attitude be around
positive people
encourage positiveness if you find
yourself walking around just complaining
all the time around people that complain
a lot man
move or just try and do something
different change your life
being positive and a positive attitude
is find something positive and something
bad
makes you look for solutions when i was
down and out okay
oh pop bottles let's get the pop bottles
cash them in
i love that because i until you said
that i knew that people listening were
thinking well it's easy for you to be
positive you're a billionaire
so but the fact that you were positive
even when you had to be looking for
the bottles to recycle to make enough
meat to get your 99 cent meals
that's incredible i had never taken a
business class
i'd never worked in fashion or retail
and i had five thousand dollars in
savings i just moved out of my mother's
house
i was 27 years old and i was probably
dating a loser at the time
so there you have it there i was
and i you know wanted to wear these
pants i didn't know where to go
so i decided i've got to get this made i
went on the internet
and i started looking up hosiery mills
and
i went to a website called
thomasregistry.com which
lists all manufacturers in the united
states now it's called thomas.net
but they listed it for me and lucky for
me most of the
hosiery manufacturers are in north
carolina well i was in atlanta georgia
at the time
so i started picking up the phone and
calling all these manufacturers
and introducing myself over the phone
and i i just
i i couldn't get the right person on the
phone people kept transferring me around
i mean i
imagine on the other end of the line
them saying you know
here there's a girl in line so she's
going to transform her own butt
like who which department am i supposed
to send her to
everyone kept either hanging up on me
saying no thanks it's not a good idea
so i believed in my own idea enough
though that i realized
okay i want to patent this i may be
having some difficulty right now getting
someone to help me make the idea
but i want to protect it so i went
and looked up on the internet martindale
hubble
which is a website that lists attorneys
and they will tell you the ranking and
you know sort of the rating next to them
i started looking for a female patent
attorney in the state of georgia
i couldn't find one so i called the
georgia chamber of commerce
and i introduced myself said i'm looking
for a female patent attorney
and they told me that there actually was
not a female patent attorney in the
state of georgia at the time
so i said okay i gotta i'm gonna go
describe this to a man
and we'll see what happens and i went on
the website i picked three different law
firms
i cold called each law firm i put on my
nicest suit from selling fax machines
that i had
i had my lucky red backpack that was
with me the entire journey of spanx
and i went and met with them well
they all quoted me between three and
five thousand dollars to patent it and i
had five thousand dollars set aside in
my savings to do this
so i decided to patent it myself
well the attorney that ended up helping
me at the very end of this process
he admitted to me that when i came to
him
with the idea that he thought my idea
was so bad when i met with him
that he actually thought i had been sent
by candid camera
which completely makes perfect sense
because i was
as i was sitting in the room explaining
it to him he kept looking around the
room and he later said to me
he said sarah i really have to tell you
i either thought you were sent by candid
camera or that i was being pranked by
some of my guy friends because
you know you whipped out the panties
you're showing me the the crotch and
where you cut these and how you're going
to change the world and
it's like i wasn't used to that your
stock at one point i think went to 100
but then it went down to six or
something like that at the peak of the
internet bubble
our stock peaked somewhere around 113
dollars
and then after the internet bubble you
know
busted open our stock went down to six
it went
from 113 to six in less than a year so
my annual shareholder that year starts
with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so most of those internet companies of
the
dot com era are out of business yeah
you survived what was that that made you
to survive and virtually the rest of
them are gone
um i it's very that whole period is very
interesting because the stock is not the
company
and the company is not the stock and so
as i watched the stock fall
from 113 to 6 i was also watching all of
our
internal business metrics number of
customers profit per unit
you know everything you can imagine
defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast
and so as the stock price was going the
wrong way everything inside the company
was going the right way
and um i you know
so i wasn't we didn't need to go back to
capital markets we didn't need more
money
the only reason you know a financial uh
bus
like the internet bubble bursting is it
makes it really hard to raise
money but you know we already had the
money we needed so we just needed to
continue to progress
look buying a jet was something i never
dreamed i'd do
i never okay i only started thinking
about it four or five years ago
when i'm young and broke i'm growing up
in louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you gotta bite on a bike be
grateful you got clothes on your back
and you get three meals be grateful for
all that you got cause you got it better
than i do i never dreamed of having my
own damn chest
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot
you do it you borrow money okay use
money
if it requires money so be it if you're
truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results
you know the secret to sustaining the
obsession is a straightforward
one focus your efforts on everything
that will fuel you
for the long run and ignore eliminate
and block out
anything that drains you or causes you
doubt
money power fame success all all of them
follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow
the problem with these things is money
power fame and success even time off
they require attention they're like
jealous lovers they need
constant attention or they're gonna
leave you how you invest your time is
more important than how you invest your
money
being obsessed with your sense of
purpose across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire i think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area of life
because they quit on all the other ones
if you quit on all the other ones how
are you going to get this one to run
nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people
who have achieved more than i have and
then meeting new people
i need the obsessed must surround
themselves with
people you trust and respect who think
big who've done bigger than you
and who can help you get to where you
want to go you think you can run only so
fast
time is no longer an excuse because the
obsessed
make time they don't make excuses this
couple came in here this morning says
bro how'd you develop this hardness you
got i said i don't know i didn't know
that i did develop a hard thing my dad
died when i was 10 though that's pretty
permanent
like you're 10 years old you're like
okay that's a that's something you
cannot negotiate with
gone is gone
all the things you wanted to say all the
things you wanted to do all the fishing
trips you wanted to have with your pops
you ain't going to have them bro okay so
you guys out there that are lucky enough
to have a dad that's alive
maybe we want to do the hard thing this
weekend you know call him
call him up maybe y'all been having this
fight for 12 years maybe you call him up
man
maybe you just go ahead and eat it you
know
quit arguing about something dumb that
happened a long time ago
do the hard thing hard things always the
right thing whether it's making
decisions in a deal to get the best deal
people like
man you're so cheap i'm buying a 168
million dollar piece of property dude i
ain't
cheap i'm smart
oh my god you don't want to pass
anything i am the only one
buying anything here i'm buying this
office building right now the
the seller's like god damn you you
you're so slippery
dude i ain't slippery i'm the only one
here trying to buy a damn place from you
right you calling me slippery why you
calling me slippery cause you slippery
i'm trying to buy the damn place okay
what you slipping on dog i ain't
slippery
i'm renegotiating right now with some
new data
we saw a fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking
and showing off and bragging and running
your mouth
you can still get cracked you got
you know huh yeah too many days off man
too many days off
you got to pay the price every day folks
otherwise you lose
period you will get beat you're going to
get beat in the marketplace if you don't
train every day
i'm wearing my cardone university
t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated
to do the right thing if you don't train
every day if you don't require training
every day if it's not mandatory every
day
you will not get the cash flow you will
get just enough money
to pay the bills and by the way
everybody's got that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree
so don't be bragging about your bicycles
and your two bmws and your country club
that you paid for
and the roof over your head and you paid
your utilities and your gas
and don't tell me that all somebody else
has got it worse than you of course
somebody else has got it worse than you
i hear this all the time from people
okay somebody gets whacked
they have a bad situation and they're
like but i'm grateful
well you mean you're grateful man you're
filing bankruptcy i know but i still got
my health
but you don't have your financial health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt
you should have prepared for it don't
make sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes
quit making sense of the failures
what do you think it'll take for you to
get over insecurity moving forward
i'm not trying you're not trying i'm not
trying to i thought you said if you
could get rid of it you'd be able to do
bigger
the unbelievable but but it's not it's
not it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of
being a human being any more than i want
to get rid of my arms
you know or my legs or my arms and my
legs my body
my body is a limitation yeah you know so
um how do you manage it better then like
for people that are saying
i you know i want a 10x but i always
have insecurity and fear
that i'm going to fail or people are
going to show up and yeah the deal is
going to i'm going to go broke
how do you personally get a conversation
to yourself
to the insecurity and fear yeah it's not
stop it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know that it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it
lean into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because
it's really dangerous and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah like
let me get to the edge of this thing i'm
gonna get on the other side of that
thing i'm probably gonna be scared
yeah now why why am i gonna be scared
though like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall you know this many floors
and hit yeah maybe it does maybe there's
no big deal about maybe dying is not
even a big deal right
but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have experience i don't have the
experience man
this this is the problem and you're not
gonna have the experience if you don't
move through the fear
and a lot of people do it once and then
they don't do it again you got
like it's not going away yeah it's just
gonna
you're gonna get used to you're gonna
get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't mend but you just wear into
them
the president of mexico was on the phone
with me today
now that is so cool but i'll tell you
what it was because i've been making
decisions to change my network
i'm turned i'm tired
over and over i am sick and tired
of
the same group that
maybe for whatever reason they're just
not happy with something i did
and and oh he did that he did this and
he said that not even like that
but dude i'm like okay i don't want to
play big games i need a new story right
so
i made the decision i went on the
chalkboard and started saying new
friends
new network don't complain about them
they are where they are it's not anybody
else's fault no
whatever i'm getting in my mind it's us
we're not satisfied with that game
we don't want a different game yeah
because everybody else is hanging around
those people they're fine they're all
having a good time and i'm the one
disappointed
so i'm the one that has to go to the
white the chalkboard
and map out oh i need a new network it's
not his fault
it's not don't be disappointed with him
i need to change nobody else in the
world needs to change
and so ever since i was 25 years old
when i went to a treatment center and
and had to confront my drug addiction
the one thing i learned there that was
so valuable was
you ha you are responsible then they
confused me with
you're responsible but it's not really
your fault because you got a disease
i'm like which one is it am i
responsible or
do i you know and i chose to say hey
it's not the deceased
i i am responsible and i haven't used
drugs for 35
36 years so um
super well done now i need to apply that
same
that same calculation to oh i want to
change my network
on the phone with the president of
mexico
the idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured
out first i got to read the instructions
first like nobody really does read the
answers i never read the answer i wrote
an article about it i don't read any
instructions you know
and so i mean i can't i can't read them
because they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah
so and that is the premise there yeah
can't
it just be simpler yeah and and the way
to make it simple is and we see this
happening today i mean
this is happening on a global scale
where picking a car up now is simple
pick me up it's crazy i don't have to
put the address in it should locate
where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go
don't even need to pay for it either
it's already i don't have to set up like
simple you guys got
everything should be simplified and the
way to simplify things i remember
mercedes benz
years ago i heard about this when they
had first figured out how to put a drop
back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old
you know they'd hang them up in the
garage and take them off and it was like
very laborious
and somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is
why apple keeps creating a crazy product
while this will go away somebody's going
to come along one day and say
get rid of the phone and i still want to
communicate
yeah and it'll probably be on a headset
more like this we'll probably we'll
probably go in here right where i'm
popping i mean
the watches yeah they're they're they're
moving there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call bye-bye
we're moving in that direction of less
and faster
and simpler so the way the human being
does that he's in brisbane this part of
the gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he
he just gets a flight no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you didn't
if you didn't know about this last night
you'd have been you'd have been doing
work about it last night planning
negotiating with the airlines when you
get compressed on time and you got a
commitment you're like i got to be there
at 2 30
everything works out yeah as i was
walking out
my assistant she goes oh where where are
you going to stay
and i was like book me a place where
close to
you know to the park or where you're
staying you won't put that out
but um we're on this trip we went to
tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life
unplanned i have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is that stretched over europe
it doesn't need to be me doing the
planning though
yeah like i think maybe i need somebody
else to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with
success resources to come here and do
these events good tell me when the
events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot
i want to let route to sydney but let's
stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai uh kids have never
been there we'll stay there for three
days acclimate for a second and
down to sydney i had enough data to know
that i would need to do a route like
that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there
i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone okay in our path
he's like grant
we can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't
go to tokyo now the point of that story
is look just keep moving forward keep
moving in a direction that you want to
go to we go to tokyo i made all these
friends in tokyo
i would have never done that but i was
committed to going to sydney
and and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer
to where you're going to go i can't
build something big
and not need people i have to have
people i become more and more dependent
upon great people loyal people uh
competent people as i get bigger so
that's what you're really looking for
opportunity will change my life when you
go work for a company when you guys make
a a a career change
go work for somebody that has
opportunity that can change
lives don't don't go where you're good
at a job it doesn't matter if you're
good at a job
go where there's a vehicle that can take
you on a journey you guys leave this
environment right now you're going to go
to some job
you're not going to get this every day
you're not going to hear this every day
you're not going to get the stimulation
they're like
what am i doing and but we all need this
every day i need it every day man i got
every day i got to be like what's the
opportunity man i got to wake up every
day what's the opportunity man huh
i got two picks up in my eyelids i'm
like what is it
what's the opportunity man huh what is
the opportunity what is opportunity
where is the opportunity and it looks
good you look good
[Laughter]
and dude i want to be able to have so
much opportunity to do so much crazy
stuff
that i can act like an idiot one of the
things that we do a little trick we do
at our company
is we always have something on our
calendar to look forward to okay if you
want to stay motivated
today's what sunday i always have
something out here out here
out here out here and out here to look
forward to
little short runways that keep me
excited okay
i'm going to turks and caicos to shoot a
real estate uh program when i leave here
yesterday i walked out of here i'm
freaking exhausted i'm like boy i can't
wait to get to turks and caicos
see it re-energizes me right
now when i'm done with that i need
something else to look forward to here i
got a whole bunch of stuff that's going
to happen here at the end of the month
that is going to keep me jacked up when
i'm at turks and caicos
because the truth is turks and caicos
could get a little boring
for a guy like me how many of you have
trouble
going on vacations you have trouble
unwinding
okay you don't even want to go you're
like i can't even enjoy this
so i need little tricks i have little
tricks everybody should do this in their
life okay
you need things to look forward to
something that you've been saying a lot
is never waste a good crisis or never
waste a good recession
what do you mean by that well what what
happens in
in contractions like the one we're
experiencing now probably probably the
most severe contraction certainly in my
lifetime
and maybe in the history the last
hundred years
possibly right um is
everybody does what they do in a
contraction not everybody not every
everybody but almost everyone goes
into non-acceptance of the situation
they go to blame conspiracy theories
uh denial they get angry about it
they lose their job they lose their
position they lose their targets
they become consumers more than ever
before
and and they lose track of hey where
were you going
you know and so if seven billion people
yesterday let's say seven billion people
a month ago were on track
big dreams big goals like everybody
wanted to expand a month ago
everybody had big dreams big goals
they're gonna change the world they're
gonna get their finances right they're
they're going for whatever they're
trying to go for whether it's a dream
house a vacation more freedom
and then boom this thing hits and
they're like oh i just want to go back
to the way it was
so immediately there's a contraction
mental contraction
yeah and and people give up i was just
having this conversation yesterday i'm
like look i've been thinking too small
the whole time
i'm telling myself this with my with two
key staff people
and i should be thinking bigger right
now not smaller how do i expand
out into this not contract
smaller into this so so the first thing
that happens is
when you when you have you know 26
million people in the united states were
let go in the last four weeks
i read something today that says the uk
housing sales
will get cut by 50 to 70 this year yeah
when that happens all of a sudden you're
like oh i just want to sell the 12 homes
i sold last year now if i could just
hold on to those 12. no you should be
thinking about how do i expand into this
because if you're not asking the right
questions you will go in the direction
of your journey
and if you're like i gotta pull over
right now that your journey wasn't to
pull over
you were on a journey a month ago you
had dreams and goals
and so when a crisis comes it's like a
speed bump a flat tire
uh you ran out of fuel what do you do
dude you fix you you
you keep rolling you fix the tire you
refuel
and you keep going and so so don't waste
this moment because we're going to pass
this is going to pass
once i decide i'm going to do something
it's like
there's no let the the chance of me
letting go of something that's important
to me
a friend like i am
either the best or worst friend a person
has why
so because because like if if if you and
i are in a club and something goes down
i will be there swinging it out
okay i have no chance of winning the
fight i can only be a distraction to the
thing
throwing a bottle but you're not gonna
see me just run yeah right so
so um
and i'm not gonna run for my dreams like
i'm not going to run for my kids i'm not
going to run from elena i'm not going to
there's nothing elena could do to cause
me to like run away from her
there is no shortage of success
regardless of their culture race
religion economic background or social
group
most people would agree that success is
vital to the well-being of the
individual the family unit
and the group and certainly to the
future survival
of all these things look without success
your group
your company your goals and dreams and
even the entire civilization would cease
to survive and thrive
winning over and over again and
everything in which you're involved
ensures you're going to be able to
further expand and survive
and it guarantees that both you and your
ideas will survive
not just get by but survive into the
future
if you quit caring then you're going to
quit winning
and if you quit winning long enough in
this thing called success
you're gonna just plain quit how would
being successful
be important to you and how would it
improve your life
look success is needed in order to
perpetuate
to push forward people places and things
you must never reduce success in your
mind
or in a conversation to something that
doesn't matter
on the contrary you must treat successes
though it's vital
it's important anyone that minimizes
the importance of success to your future
has probably given up on his or her own
chances
of accomplishment and is spending now
his or her life trying to convince
others
you in this case to also give up
individuals and groups must actively
accomplish their goals and targets
in order to carry on with their goals
and targets
if not look they'll either cease to
exist
or be consumed and become part of
something else
it's not enough just to play the game
it's vital you learn
how to win at this game now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the billionaire mindset
question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar get ready for another amazing
video tomorrow or if you don't have it
yet you can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got all the tools
available to you
it has never been easier to build your
dreams to reach an audience to create
the company you want
never easier all you're missing is
momentum
sustained daily ever-present momentum
and today i'm going to show you how to
get it one of the only reasons why i've
had success on youtube is i just kept
going
when i first started on the platform 11
years ago it's crazy that it's been that
long you can
kind of see some of the awards behind me
here behind the the books by bill to
serve it's an amazing book
11 years ago when i first started my
first video was on walt disney i had my
friend mark draker huge friend of the
channel
come in and help film it for me and help
edit for me
and in the first year of that video
being up there were only three comments
on it
one was my mom one was my older sister
and one was some other random guy who
commented on my video
right in a year of my first video going
up only one person that i didn't know
commented on the video youtube at the
time was not a long form platform
youtube 11 years ago was something that
people were posting really silly meme
videos and just
jokes and pranks but really short form
videos nobody was making long videos 10
minute videos 12 minutes
it didn't exist and it took me five
years to get to
7 000 subscribers i knew because that's
when i passed 1 million views after 5
years
i crossed a million views and i got 7
000 subscribers
and then in the past six years it's gone
from seven thousand subscribers to two
point whatever million and
a million views to 300 whatever million
views
i just kept at it now my journey doesn't
have to be your journey it doesn't have
to take you
that long if you're trying to build up a
youtube channel it may but it doesn't
have to one
i'm super introverted and nervous and
and filming and even now this stuff
makes me nervous get in front of the
camera because i want every video to be
the best that i've ever done
youtube at the time was not an
educational platform that has changed so
there's lots that was against me but the
only reason why i
passed so many other creators is just
because i kept going
because i had the thing that most people
miss which is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum it was actually sad for me
for when i passed some of the speakers
that i looked up to and i aspired to be
like from a speaker point of view
because i figured these guys are so much
more talented to me these guys have
so many more abilities than me they're
more naturally gifted and they put in so
much work to be great speakers
and it made me sad when i passed them on
youtube because i felt man these guys
they should be out there more i feel
like their message needs to be heard
the only difference was i was just
putting in more work on youtube they're
off doing other things as well but
from a youtube perspective i was just
building more momentum i just had more
sustained energy to it and you see this
so often with entrepreneurs not just
youtube
entrepreneurs so often you got a great
idea and you start and there's so much
energy and momentum and then
and then you don't get immediate results
and so you stop and then you get
motivated again and you keep going
and then and then you quit again and you
and you give up it's that
sustained evergreen ongoing daily
momentum that you're missing
even if it's just an hour a day maybe
you have a job you need to survive
awesome
i understand yes pay the bills you don't
have to burn all the boats and burn all
the bridges
as the only way that this business is
going to take off
sustain momentum every single day has to
be part of what you're doing and so i've
had success on youtube because i've made
6 000 videos again i'm not
super talented it took me a long time to
get here
i'm i'm a result of just every day
getting up and doing the work and
chances are whoever your heroes are
whether it's tony robbins
or steve jobs or oprah winfrey whoever
it is look at their story
it was every day getting up doing the
work
even if they weren't getting results
knowing that the only thing
missing the only thing you are missing
is that sustained
momentum because you're a genius you
have a great idea
that idea needs to be birthed into the
world you're just not doing enough
daily action to make it actually happen
you are staying small because you're
afraid
you're afraid of the worst case scenario
coming true losing
having no money and being embarrassed
but you know you're capable of more
you know the way that you're going about
doing things right now
is nothing compared to what you're
capable of
unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always going to stay small
knowing that you are capable of more
today i'm going to show you how
so one of the easiest ways to get out of
your scarcity mindset is to go from idea
to action as soon as you get an idea you
do something about it
and sometimes that idea often that idea
is going to be
too big too scary too crazy you can't do
it who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy
right all of that all of the excuses
that come into your head i like to teach
myself that as soon as i get an idea i
go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something
every time you say i can't you're
teaching yourself that you suck
because you've quit because you've given
up it's not your fault that you can't do
it
it's your work or your school or your
family or all the other commitments that
you have but not your fault
nope nope nope
change your i can't to either i'm going
to or i
choose not to that's how you take back
control of your decisions
and your life so i recently listened to
this chinese song and i got obsessed
with it i got obsessed with it i was
playing
all day long and i just i loved i don't
know what they're saying i don't know
which i don't know what the
the words mean i just loved i loved it i
loved it
i go to bed and lyrics start coming to
me
rap lyrics in full sentences right the
first one comes in okay wake up i'm in
bed i'm lying in bed i'm trying to sleep
you know it's 11 o'clock trying to sleep
i said
idea rap lyric come okay i write it down
again wrap layers come write it down
more more and more write it down until
three in the morning i haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like i need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what
you can make a wrap it's easy to get
locked in into i can't mode
i can't do this i can't start that i
can't do a rap i didn't go to school for
that
and not that you go to school for rap
you know i didn't rap growing up
i don't have musical talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect from me i can't rap
that's where most people quit but
instead
i decided i was gonna get up at three
something in the morning
go to my computer finish writing out my
lyrics and then i spent the day
rapping and that night finished the
video
sent it off to christina my editor to
put it together and the next day would
release my rap video
now maybe you love it maybe you hate it
it's gotten some decent responses
it was tons of fun to put together and
most importantly
i taught myself and all of these things
these are all great micro moments to
teach yourself
that you're amazing whenever you say i
can't
and you do it that's how you build
self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love
self-respect is taking something that
you think that you can't do
and just trying not even
doing it full out because i don't expect
my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but i tried it
i did it
i released it expect a second beginning
that's okay it's normal it's part of the
process
but in those moments of i can't and then
turning them into something that
actually exists
is where your genius will come i look at
my top 10 series and
it's partly why i have kanye on my wall
because the first video that i made was
on kanye
first top 10 was on kanye was five years
into my youtube career
i did a response to my friend mark
drager
from phantom media and i said initially
i can't do this
like i can't make a video now on this i
have all these other commitments i have
a full day ahead of other stuff that i'm
supposed to do and said no
i need action i'm just going to do it
forget it i'm going to make it
and i didn't expect it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making
i don't know how many top tens hundreds
maybe a thousand i don't know how many
top ten how many times have i done i
have no idea
but it started off as just idea trust
your ideas
know that they're amazing stop saying i
can't to yourself
this is where you need to take control
of your head in your heart you have to
make decisions
with your heart and then use your head
to figure out how to do it
anytime you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new i'm making it i'm going to make a
wrap
i'm going to make a top 10 video i'm
going to do anything outside my normal
thing right same for you
anytime you're doing something new it
doesn't make
sense because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense
you're creating something new and so
your head your logical brain that's
designed to keep you safe
doesn't understand it its job is to to
protect you and says don't do that
you can't do that because one has ever
been done and because we have
all these reasons why it's not possible
for you not just anybody else for you
that you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says
your heart can create something new your
heart creates art
your heart makes up a world that hasn't
existed before
and so at the very beginning of many
projects your head and your heart are
against each other
your heart's saying i want to make this
your heart she can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum
because your your head and your heart
are fighting you've got your foot on the
gas and the break at the same time
never moving knowing that you're capable
of more and so you make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
and then you rally your head to say okay
we're doing this i'm making the rap
video i'm making the top ten
you're gonna do your crazy idea and then
your head says oh
okay they're serious let's figure out
how not to die doing this
right let's figure out how to actually
make it work so you make the big
decisions in life with the heart
and then you use your head to figure out
how to go out and accomplish it the
easiest way to win
is to do work that you love making a new
video is easy for me i've done
six thousand plus videos i still love
them i still enjoy it
but there is a chandelier sitting in the
trunk of my car right now that i have no
interest in installing i have i have no
idea how to install a light i have no
interest in learning how to install a
light and so i've asked my friend mark
drager from fanta
to come and help install the light for
me if you're doing a business that you
don't know
and that you don't love and you think
it's just going to be easy money
news flash it's never just easy money
you're going to lose you have to go
through what i call the blinders test
now blinders are things that people put
on horses
so there's those black patches that they
put here on the side of the horse so the
horse doesn't get distracted so the
horse isn't like
going all over like this all they can
see is what's in front of them and it
forces them to just focus and go in
front of them
now side note apparently they actually
have this for humans too
and some tech companies are using them
where they have blinders for humans
that seems a little crazy to me but
listen if blinders help you focus
then by all means go for it but you need
to pass the blinders test so what is the
blinder says
for me it's those moments in time where
you have
absolute clarity for what you need to do
where you know where you want to go
where you have
direction and purpose and this is the
window that you need to jump
through for me right now it's youtube
yes i've been on the platform for over
10 years but this is a special moment in
time
for youtube right now for evan
carmichael plus youtube right now
i'm hitting it on strides we've got i
don't know how many channels right now
a lot too many maybe but i want to have
100 channels this is a moment in time
youtube's not going to be around forever
and it's going to morph and it's going
to become something else
and i'm going to have different
interests at some point this is the
moment of time that you need to then
push
hard i see opportunities as windows
there's this window that's in front of
you right now
and the window's open but it's not going
to be open forever
at some point that window of opportunity
is going to shut
and that's when people look back and say
i had i could have done it and
and that other person they made so much
money off of my idea it wasn't your idea
they did it the only difference between
you
and the people who are winning is they
started they did it they take action
every single day there's no reason
why that person can't be you you have to
jump through the window with full force
and put your blinders on and stop
thinking about everything else that's
around you
that's if you have absolute clarity and
direction now there will be other
moments in your life
and i think i think life moves like this
i think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute clarity and
purpose and direction
and there'll be other moments where
you're not so sure what to do
and then you have to open up the funnel
again sticking
to the blinders when you don't know what
you're doing is not a great strategy
this this happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs where they have focus for
their business but then they lose
interest in their business
and then they bought themselves a job
and they're too afraid to get out of
that business
because of what it means because of the
opportunity cost because of everything
that they've
they've sunk into the business because
people might say well what a failure if
they close now
and they should have been out of their
business three years ago but they're
still going don't let that be you you're
never gonna win doing work that you hate
if you don't like your business anymore
you need to adjust it or you need to
move on
dump it move on to something else if i
stop liking videos
i will just decide no more videos
happening sorry guys
maybe sell it to somebody else or just
stop because i'm not going to win doing
work that i hate either
and so if you feel your foot kind of
pulling out of the water while you still
have some interest move on to the next
thing
and so when you know what you want to do
you're focused hyper focused that's all
you're doing when you don't know what
you want to do
you open up the scope and that's okay
and i think
everybody will go through these phases
in life you will have
absolute clarity and so you need to go
off and do instead of finding all the
reasons why you can't do
and when you don't know what you want to
do don't stress out and worry that you
don't know what you want to do try
a bunch of stuff say yes to everything
pay attention to the feeling the most
important thing when you're trying
something new
is do you love the process of it not is
this going to be your next big
opportunity did you love the process
even though you sucked doing it i suck
making my first
video i love the process i suck when i
first learn salsa dancing i love the
process
you're supposed to suck at the start
that's okay you don't need to get
instant results
if you love the process you will win if
you got instant results
but you don't love it you're never going
to win it's just never going to happen
you're not going to win
and so depending where you are on this
spectrum of absolute clarity
to having no idea dictates what your
actions should be
when you know what you need to do stop
making excuses stop having justification
and just go off and do the damn thing
and if you don't know what you want to
do
then explore stop feeling sorry for
yourself stop complaining it's okay
explore you will find the thing that
then you can focus on until the next
time you expand
comparison to other people i think is
actually
a good thing i think you need it i think
it helps you
i think it serves you the problem is
most people look at other people
start feeling insecure and then kick
themselves down
the key is to kick yourself forward
not down but you need that kick
otherwise you stay where you are this is
one of the reasons why i love modern
success why i created all my youtube
channels and all the content that i've
done and have the people behind me on
the wall
because i love looking at other people i
love learning from other people i love
seeing somebody do
amazing things and say that's what's
possible
this is what's possible i look at les
brown as an example and i think he's the
greatest speaker of all time
at least that i've i've seen i don't
maybe maybe the ancient greeks were
better i don't know but
but les brown modern era on video i
think is the greatest speaker
and i look at that and say that's what's
possible not that
i can't do that here's what most people
do they look at les brown and say well i
can't do that
and then they start feeling insecure and
i'm just i'm just an imposter trying to
be like that now
and then they quit and then they feel
they feel low
self-esteem when they and they beat
themselves up over because they're not
les brown
i look at les brown and say that's
what's possible this is what this is
what humans can actually accomplish and
achieve
i want some of that i want to get better
i want to drive and improve
not to be the next les brown but he's
the best me but this is what's possible
i look at david goggins
man david goggins look he came out of
nowhere who was david goggins did you
guys know david goggins five years ago
no he blew up out of nowhere
because of the passion and intensity and
truth of his message
right i love that and it's easy to say
and look at that well look at how
passionate david goggins is and look how
he blew up i can never do that
i'm not as strong as him i'm not as
crazy as him i don't have the same
mindset as him and so i can't do that
and you compare yourself to goggins and
then you say well i can't i can't and so
you don't start that's the problem
you should look at gawkins and say look
at what's possible
you could come from nowhere nobody
knowing who you are
and in a short amount of time blow up
because you have a message that matters
you can look at how passionate he is
about his message
every video he's got insane passion
right
this guy he's not going to give you nice
hugs and compliments
but he he cares about his message right
you can see that
and you could take that as as what's
possible you can you can care deeply
about your message too
and model david goggins and and apply
that to make your message stronger and
better
i think if you just were competing with
yourself i think you're actually going
to suck
i think i think if you're the best at
something and you don't have any
competition
i think you actually suck being the big
fish in a small pond
actually limits a lot of creativity uh
limits your ability to go off and crush
things
i think i think it is i think when you
even even in animals when you see
animals going up against each other in a
race when
when somebody's close you work a little
bit harder right i think i think we need
that in our ecosystem
the key though again is to make sure
you're kicking yourself forward to say
this is what is possible
not this person's so much better than me
i suck feeling insecure
feeling depressed you need the kick just
make sure you're kicking yourself
forward
not down the biggest mistake so many
entrepreneurs make is they jump into a
business because they see that it's a
hot opportunity
you don't love it you don't know much
about it but so many people are talking
about it and it looks like an easy way
to make a lot of money
big mistake don't do that it's the
fastest way to go broke
so warren buffett did not invest in
amazon but he's still done
pretty well for himself he didn't invest
in amazon because he doesn't like tech
he doesn't know it he doesn't love it he
doesn't live in that space and so he
doesn't want to buy those kinds of
companies
and great he missed out on amazon but he
also missed out on all the tech
companies that didn't make it
that he could have put money into that
just would have gone to zero he knows
what he's great at he knows what he
loves and he sticks
in his arena i look at what i'm doing
there's so many opportunities that come
my way that i know nothing about
i have no interest in i don't want to
have interest in that i'm
i'm losing money on right i don't like
real estate
i hate real estate i don't want to i
want to be in it i don't want to learn
about it i don't like real estate
it's not that it's not a good
opportunity it's just not for me it's
boring to me i have zero interest in
real estate
it's great for so many people so many
people have
built amazing wealth and generational
wealth based off of real estate
amazing i'm pumped for you it's just not
the thing that i want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert
i know nothing about cryptocurrency i've
bought zero cryptocurrency in my life
i've been given
zero cryptocurrency in my life is
cryptocurrency the future
yep when is it gonna come i don't know
is it gonna be bitcoin i don't know
i i don't know anything about
cryptocurrency i get the mechanics and
the general theory and i know that it's
coming
but it's not the opportunity for me cbd
is a big thing now right everybody's
getting the cbd and cbd oils and cbd
products and
great and it's becoming legal here in
canada it already is legal in a bunch of
our provinces and
it's going to be legalized across many
states if not the whole country
awesome it's not me i don't i don't i'm
not in the cbd
i don't i don't smoke any marijuana i
never have i'm not interested in it
it may help you it may alleviate your
pain amazingness may be the greatest
gift you've ever seen in your life
amazing but if you're only jumping into
it because you think it's a hot
opportunity
you're gonna lose that being said i'm
also involved in so many things
that are hot opportunities i'm drowning
in opportunities i have too many
opportunities that i know what to do
with let alone don't know what to do
with
looking at youtube youtube right now is
still a massive opportunity there's so
many people
who look at what i've done who look at
what gary have done and grant cardone
and those guys have done and say i want
to do it
youtube is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader
if you want to have educational content
youtube is still
a huge opportunity most people who are
the experts
at what they do are not on youtube that
means you can go on even with a little
bit less expertise and go and crush it
because the people who are the best in
the world are doing it they're not doing
it
it's a huge opportunity it's a big white
space still right now
even though i've been on it for 10 years
youtube has evolved a lot over the past
decade and there's still
tons of white space open and available i
need to push the opportunity harder
i look at thought leadership that's
another one thought leadership the stuff
that i'm doing the videos like this
the teaching that i've done the
workshops that i've done people want to
be a thought leader
not just an influencer but a thought
leader and i'm at the center of that
trend i'm helping train a lot of thought
leaders people are coming to me asking
me for help
in becoming a thought leader in making
content and being able to do good videos
and be able to get speaking gigs
book deals all of it people want it it's
happening and i'm at the center of that
trend too
league of legends i love league of
legends i've been playing league of
legends
for this is six years this is my sixth
year playing league of legends i played
teemo look i got
i got i got teemo here i got teemo here
i got tristana here i've named my dogs
timon tristana right i play three games
a night on my twitch stream you can come
to my twitch stream twitch.tv
slash believe team come join me i play
there three games a night i'm trying to
get the gold
uh this season which means i'm in the
top 10 of players
uh in north america so that's my it's my
ambition for the year
i watch league of legends every weekend
i have a tsm jersey
let me get it i have a tsm jersey i'm a
fan
i love league of legends i love esports
if you are getting into esports
just because it's a hot opportunity and
you don't love it you're gonna die
you're gonna lose
i look at garyvee as an example and
gary's done an amazing job in hip-hop
an amazing job in hip-hop and he's
brought so many different artists on
from the top of nipsy hustle all the way
down to people who are just
breaking in and trying to get their
start he loves hip-hop he loves the
lyrics he loves the culture and so he's
really built a name for himself inside
of hip-hop
he got into twitch a little bit he had a
twitch studio set up
in his office and he started doing a
little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades
and so it's not authentic for him and so
he's not going to win there
i love esports i love league of legends
i love gaming
it's part of what i do i can talk to you
about the current roster
for tsm and my thoughts on it i could
talk about the new patch that came out
on league of legends and how teemo is
doing i like it it's just
i i genuinely like it and so i have
these opportunities in front of me
already within youtube within thought
leadership within esports that that i
can
take advantage of and blow up in and i
don't need to worry about
real estate and cryptocurrency and cbd
and all the other
millions of opportunities out there
there's already tons of opportunities
inside the things that you already know
and love the things that you know and
love
there's lots of people who know and love
that thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers
you could be the person who gives them
the answers jumping on some train
because you think it's a hot opportunity
and a chance to make money is the
fastest way that you will lose money
because you don't understand anything
about that
if you don't love esports don't go spend
money on an esports team
you're gonna lose you don't even know
what you're doing inside the things that
you love and know
is a tremendous opportunity and that's
what you need to focus on
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there